hablemos de la interferencia de película
delgada aunque esto es algo redundante
ya que película se refiere a algo que es
de por sí muy delgado y una película
delgada es algo muy muy muy delgado como
ocurre esto puede suceder de forma
natural al llover nos encontraremos
charcos de agua y a veces en la calle
nos encontraremos restos de aceite los
cuales van a flotar por encima del agua
y esto será muy delgado ya que tendremos
una cantidad muy pequeña de aceite en
otras palabras el grosor del aceite que
está flotando por encima del agua es
extremadamente delgado lo vamos a llamar
t como sabemos que está ahí y que es tan
delgado sabemos que está aquí porque si
observamos el agua desde arriba a veces
aquí veremos un patrón de colores y ese
patrón de colores por encima del agua
rayas de color rojo azul naranja verde
se deben a la interferencia de película
delgada y eso también ocurre en las
burbujas si ustedes hacen una burbuja
observarán estos patrones de colores en
su superficie y éstas se deben a la
interferencia de película delgada como
ocurre esto pues tenemos que la luz
viene por acá puede ser del sol o de
cualquier otra fuente de luz viene por
acá y este es un solo rayo de luz y
necesitamos varios rayos de luz para
poder tener interferencia que pasa
cuando este rayo de luz llega al aceite
pues una parte de esta luz se va a
reflejar va a reflejarse directamente
aquí pero como ya tengo esta línea si la
dibujo encima se va a complicar esto
mejor la voy a dibujar acá lo que se
refleja de este rayo de luz
hacia acá
si es que viniera directamente hacia
abajo a este rayo de luz le vamos a
llamar rayo 1
pero esto no es todo lo que hace la luz
parte de ella se refleja pero parte de
ella pasa a través del aceite y para que
ocurra la interferencia de película
delgada
esta película delgada tiene que ser
traslúcida debe dejar pasar la luz no
solo reflejar la sino permitir que parte
de la luz pase aquí y diremos que esto
es lo que alcanza a pasar de la luz en
el aceite y qué más ocurre aquí pues
aquí llega a otra interfase y cada vez
que la luz se encuentra en una interfase
entre dos medios una parte de ella se va
a reflejar y otra va a pasar o se va a
retractar así que en este caso parte de
la luz se va a reflejar en esta
interfase y también tenemos una
reflexión aquí
ambas son reflexiones
qué parte de esta luz se va a reflejar
aquí directo pero no lo voy a dibujar
acá voy a dibujarlo justo acá
esta es la luz que se refleja hasta el
ojo y ahora sí voy a tener dos rayos de
luz que van a interferir ahora que
tenemos los rayos 1 y 2 que se están
trasladando y es ahora cuando mi ojo va
a percibir la interferencia ya que
tenemos estos rayos 1 y 2 que se están
trasladando y quizás tengan
interferencia constructiva o destructiva
y aquí puedo observar diferentes colores
dependiendo de las longitudes de onda
esto es lo que queremos encontrar ver
como dependiendo del grosor de la capa
de aceite y la longitud de onda van a
determinar si esta interferencia va a
ser constructiva destructiva o ninguna
de las dos esto es lo que sabemos y no
nos vamos a desviar de lo que ya
conocemos sabemos que para tener una
interferencia constructiva con dos rayos
de luz
importante es la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta si esta diferencia
es igual a 0
o a lambda a dos veces lambda oa
cualquier entero x lambda nos va a dar
una interferencia constructiva
constructiva
y siempre que la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta sea la mitad de una
lambda es decir lambda entre 2 o 3
lambda entre 2 etcétera que podemos
generalizar como m más un medio x lambda
tendremos una interferencia destructiva
destructiva
bueno esto no es igual a que sea
constructivo o destructivo sino que
implica que la interferencia será
constructiva o destructiva pero
recuerden que aquí debemos tener cuidado
ya que estas se van a intercambiar
dependiendo si ambos rayos de luz están
en fase o desfasados esto va a ocurrir
si hay
desfase de una de las fuentes
de ti
si uno de los rayos tiene un desfase de
pi y el otro no recordemos el ejemplo de
las bocinas si modificamos las
terminales de la parte de atrás de una
de las bocinas en lugar de tener una
onda que salga de la bocina de esta
forma vamos a tener una onda que va a
salir así y si trasladamos ambas ondas
ahora en este caso tendremos una
interferencia destructiva y en este caso
una constructiva se van a intercambiar
si no recuerdan esto vean el vídeo de
interferencia de onda esta es la
condición múltiplos enteros de la
longitud de onda nos van a dar
interferencia constructiva múltiplos de
la mitad de la longitud de onda nos van
a dar interferencia destructiva a menos
que una de las fuentes tenga un desfase
de pi
si ambas fuentes están desfasadas pib es
es pues vamos a tener igual la fase y
esta condición se va a mantener pero si
una de ellas está desfasada
intercambiamos estas relaciones y ahora
los múltiplos enteros de la longitud de
onda van a tener interferencia
destructiva y en los múltiplos de la
mitad de la longitud de la onda tendrán
interferencia constructiva esto es algo
que nos tiene que preocupar en este
ejemplo cuando vimos el vídeo de la
interferencia de doble ranura no nos
preocupaba esto ya que teníamos una sola
onda que era la que llegaba aquí y lo
que pasaba por aquí nos aseguramos que
estaba en fase porque venían de la misma
fuente pero qué sucede ahora en el caso
de la interferencia de película delgada
en este caso podremos tener un desfase
de pi pues si cada que tenemos un cambio
de medio podemos tener un desfasamiento
de pi
va de nuevo
una vez que la luz se refleja podría
ocurrir un desplazamiento de pi como
sabemos si esto ocurre pues va a
depender de la velocidad de la luz en
los materiales
digamos que aquí afuera tenemos aire
y la luz va a tener cierta velocidad en
el aire que resulta que es muy similar a
la velocidad de la luz en el vacío que
es de 3 por 10 a la 8 metros por segundo
pero la voy a escribir como la velocidad
en el aire
y la luz va a tener cierta velocidad
cuando viaje en el aceite así que
tenemos de de aceite
la luz viajará a cierta velocidad en el
aceite digamos que la velocidad del
aceite es de 2.7 por 10 a la 8 metros
por segundo y la luz también va a tener
cierta velocidad en el agua y sabemos
que la velocidad de la luz en el agua es
de 2.25 por 10 a la 8 metros por segundo
y ahora que conocemos estas velocidades
como podemos determinar si va a haber un
desplazamiento de pi o no pues vamos a
saberlo siempre que la luz se refleje en
un medio más lento ahí vamos a tener un
desfase de pi por ejemplo está la luz
aquí en el aire viaja por acá y llega el
aceite el aceite tiene una velocidad
menor que la que tiene el aire por lo
que en este punto de reflexión va a
haber un desplazamiento
así que pasa de un medio donde tiene una
velocidad pues bastante buena hacia un
medio que no es tan veloz entonces aquí
en este punto tenemos un desfasamiento
de pi digamos que este rayo de luz al
tocar el aceite estaba en un pico al
pasar a este medio que es más lento en
donde la luz no viaja tan fácilmente su
reflejo va a tener un desfasamiento es
decir que esta luz reflejada va a
reflejarse iniciando con un valle y si
este rayo de luz llegó como un punto que
va hacia arriba su reflejo va a salir
como un punto que va hacia abajo va a
tener un desfasamiento de 180 grados o
de pi y qué pasa con este punto de aquí
abajo se refleja en un medio más lento
pues si aquí la velocidad del aceite era
de 2.7
y la velocidad en el agua es de 2 puntos
25 en el agua no deja que la luz viaje
tan fácilmente como lo hizo en el aceite
así que aquí también tendremos un
desfasamiento de pie y tendremos lo
mismo si llego como un pico va a salir
como un valle que va a pasar con esta
condición de aquí
bueno pues tenemos que ambos rayos de
luz tienen desfasamiento depp y los dos
y esto es lo mismo que si ninguno de los
dos tuviera un desfasamiento si ambas
ondas están invertidas pues no tenemos
ningún problema todo está bien por lo
que en este caso no vamos a intercambiar
estas condiciones
si por alguna razón aquí no usáramos
agua sino cualquier otro líquido
y en este líquido la velocidad de la luz
fuera diferente vamos a decir que es de
2.85 por 10 a la 8 metros por segundo
pues esto no cambiaría nada de lo que
sucede aquí arriba aquí seguiríamos
teniendo un desplazamiento de pie pues
tenemos a la luz que está pasando por el
aire y llega a un medio donde su
velocidad es más lenta aquí tenemos este
desplazamiento aquí en el aceite la luz
no se va a mover con tanta facilidad
como lo hizo en el aire por eso es que
decimos que este es un medio más lento
pero qué pasa cuando este rayo de luz
pasa del aceite a este líquido que es
más rápido del medio en el que estaba
pues aquí va a haber una reflexión pero
ya no voy a tener mi desplazamiento de
pi porque está pasando de un medio más
lento hacia uno donde se mueve más
rápido así que en este caso solo
uno de mis rayos involucrados tendrá el
desfasamiento en pie aquí si voy a
aplicar el intercambiar estas
condiciones así que si tenemos que si
hay desfase de pi en una de las ondas
entonces vamos a hacer este intercambio
de condiciones en donde ahora los
múltiplos de la mitad de la longitud de
la onda nos van a dar interferencia
constructiva y los múltiplos de la
longitud de onda completa nos dará la
interferencia destructiva
vamos a aclarar esto un poco mejor si yo
tengo un material que es lento
y junto tengo un material que es más
rápido
si tenemos que se va a reflejar en un
material rápido entonces no habrá
no habrá
desfasamiento
de pie
no habrá desplazamiento de 180 grados
pero si pasaremos de un medio que es
rápido
rápido hacia un medio que es lento
y tenemos que se refleja en el material
lento entonces sí habrá en este caso si
habrá un desfasamiento de 180°
desfasamiento
de pie
y con esto sabemos si habrá
desplazamiento si se refleja en un
material rápido o si se refleja en un
material lento y esto sucede también
para el medio de aquí arriba tenemos que
preguntarnos lo mismo si estamos pasando
de un medio que sea lento a uno que es
rápido o si se está reflejando en un
medio rápido o al revés si estamos en un
medio rápido y la onda se va a reflejar
en un medio lento así es como sabemos si
habrá desplazamiento si se refleja en un
medio que es rápido no habrá
desplazamiento si se refleja en un
material lento entonces sí habrá
desplazamiento y así es como
determinamos si habrá desplazamiento
aquí hay otros detalles que tenemos que
ver hay muchas personas que se les
complica trabajar con esta interferencia
de película delgada un problema es que
no saben distinguir si hay desfase de pi
o no lo cual no es tan difícil de
determinar una vez conociendo la regla
pero aquí hay otro problema cuál es
delta x pues va a estar relacionada con
el grosor del aceite imaginemos que
tenemos las dos ondas y ambas ondas
vienen por acá juntas están combinadas
una vez que llegan a este medio mi radio
uno va a viajar esta distancia de aquí
acá
cuando se refleje y la onda 2 también va
a recorrer oa viajar esta distancia pero
lo va a hacer después de haber recorrido
esta distancia extra mientras estuvo en
esta película delgada así que la
longitud extra que viaja nuestra onda 2
comparada con la onda 1 no es el grosor
t muchas personas piensan que esta
diferencia esta delta x es el grosor t
pero no la onda tuvo que viajar hacia
abajo y después viajar hacia arriba por
lo que esta diferencia es 2 t esta es la
clave para la interferencia de película
delgada la diferencia en la longitud de
la ruta siempre va a ser dos veces este
y ahora voy a quitar esto porque ya sé
exactamente cuánto vale esta diferencia
en la longitud del desplazamiento
siempre va a ser dos y te recordemos que
es el grosor de la película delgada esta
es mi condición y es lo que tengo que
cambiar para hacer esto relevante para
la interferencia de película delgada
recordemos que para la doble ranura
delta x era de porsche no detecta pero
para la interferencia de película
delgada delta x siempre va a ser este 2
t es más sencillo aunque bueno aquí
tenemos que preocuparnos si hay un
desfase de pi o no pero al menos la
delta x es sencilla hay algo más que nos
preocupe aquí si hay una cosa más